of all the insults out there in the
world especially in the world of
politics you're a lion dog faced pony
soldier there is one that stands head
and shoulders above the rest
that is the insult cuck excuse me
boy cuck [ __ ] short for cuckold uh
refers to a man
whose woman sleeps with other men
this is a very old-timey insult i know
that it's only really come into fashion
in recent years in america but in italy
this is one of the oldest insults there
is cornuto italians wear little horns on
their neck to ward off the malocchio the
evil eye to protect against becoming a
cuckold so the word is deep in western
culture and now it's coming into the
mainstream and unfortunately
even the act of being a cuckold is
coming into the mainstream some people
are even willingly doing it you get back
here you make love to my wife people
bandy the word about and they call each
other cucks all the time
we are going to analyze the top
actual
cockles of tick tock
[Music]
so i i guess they're
i
the guys are both dating the girl
and you know in a true
cuckold type situation it would be a
straight guy
has this girl and then the girl
you know goes off with some other
straight guy and then here though i'm
not sure if it's quite that it might be
there might be a little more ambiguity
here in the sexual desire and i am
judging that entirely by the mustache
ambiguously gay duel not suggesting that
these fellas are necessarily a little
light in the loafers but they don't
well they don't seem
necessarily the straightest guys in the
world either way i guess technically
technically that would
i guess technically that might qualify
as cuckolding all right next one hey man
i think you should know that i saw your
wife with another man
did they have leftovers
what
did they have
a bag
of food
yes
who
was holding
the bag
she
was
[ __ ] yeah
that's pretty funny actually i guess
because we're living in this culture
where all
uh parody and satire are dead you're
welcome i don't know if this guy is
being earnest or not or if he's kind of
making fun of cuckolds and then the the
expectation would be that the guy would
be very upset that his wife is stupid
another guy but you know he just he's
kind of joking about how cuckolds only
care about eating food there's actually
a pla an opera about this by rossini
called litaliana in algeria where at the
end the way that they resolve this issue
of a guy a guy's wife shtupping this
other guy is that she just cooks him a
lot of food and he calls himself
papatachi and just stuffs his face
so
i find this pretty funny it would be
much sadder if we were to later find out
that this guy actually is a cuckold
himself but as of now i think it's
pretty funny
surveillance is increasing and it's not
just that people want your data when
you're looking at things that you
shouldn't be looking at people want your
data especially when you're looking at
things you should be looking at when
ordinary conservative people are just
stating plain truths online looking at
news websites looking for the fact very
often those three letter agencies very
often big tech they will go in there
they will look at your data they can
sell your data unless you're using
expressvpn i use expressvpn on all my
devices it takes one click and i am
protected they protect your identity
they protect your data
you can't have people looking into your
unique ip address on your devices it's
phenomenal they just anonymize that
identity using a secure vpn server they
encrypt 100
of your internet data for protection
from any eavesdroppers or cyber
criminals expressvpn makes it super easy
i've got everyone i'm recommending
everyone to use this because it's just
that one button even i can use it stop
handing your data over to the government
and big tech companies defend your
rights with the same vpn that i use and
trust expressvpn.com
michael knowles show to get three extra
months for free or click the link in my
description below all right more
cuckolds i'm gonna beat my boyfriend
tonight why do you gotta be so
aggressive during board games until she
starts losing and then she starts
sulking and cheating i don't cheat
yeah you do
what
i'm super loyal to us maybe but when it
comes to board games you're like a like
a female future he is so right i'm so
happy you have another boyfriend that
sees this
i don't think this counts as
cuckoldry because i these are obviously
just two gay guys and they've got you
know half gay guys and they're dating
this girl and they're but it's not
in a real in a real
the tradition of cuckolding it would be
some poor schmuck who is thinks he's
just dating this girl and then some guy
comes in and and
takes the girl so i don't i don't know
that that quite counts i mean this is
extremely depraved and sad and i'm i
feel sorry for every single person
involved here and for all of us who have
to witness this in our society it's so
sad so sad but i don't know i don't know
that i would call them cuckolds exactly
so zach and i had been together for
um we had been married for about eight
years and i told him that i had feelings
for um a close friend of mine
and that sparked hundreds of
conversations over um
almost two years yeah this guy's
um we actually were polyamorous so we
were just talking about it and
i was reading every book that i could
find and just trying to you know figure
all the ins and outs of it and figure
out how to do it right from the
beginning um
i know we didn't we did a terrible job
and i think most people do when you're
trying to undo a lifetime of monogamy
and you know heteronormative like life
so it was actually you know a really
beautiful time because
we had been together every day for years
and really didn't know each other
wholly and completely so getting to to
know each other all over again and it
was really um it was really beautiful
especially in the beginning we didn't
know each other completely this is sad i
mean this this is actually cuckold and
you can see the poor guy right he's he's
in a lower position and he's kind of
leaning on her shoulder and he she's
leading the whole thing she's like yeah
you're i'm not really that into you and
so i wanted a boyfriend and then you
clearly spent two years telling me not
to and i told you i'm going to do it
anyway and then you were
so
weak in your conviction and your view of
marriage that you decided to let me burn
down our marriage and then and now i'm
dating other men you have played so hard
you cuck especially sad that they're
married too it's not even that they have
just some weird romantic entanglement i
mean they took a vow and marriage
means something whether society
acknowledges that or not and it's it's
really just sad and pathetic but i love
that part at the end there she says and
now you know we were married for a long
time and we were honoring our vows and
then i decided to go stop other guys and
that that is how we really got to know
each other it's a beautiful story
as if you can only really know someone
when you go wrong when you do something
really bad and you are encouraged in
that vice as though just being good and
restraining your base appetites and your
worst desires as though that's not the
real you the only the only real you is
your appetite this is the complete
opposite of how we have traditionally in
our culture certainly in christian
civilization have thought of humanity
because we have two wills i talk about
this a fair bit on the show we have a
lower will that's the appetite we have a
higher will which is the rational will
so the lower will says i want to do a
bunch of drugs and i want to eat more
cookies and i want to stop everybody i
see then the rational will says no i
actually don't want to do that because i
know that's bad for me and i know that
the drugs are going to make me feel bad
and the cookies are going to be a tummy
ache and the shipping everyone i see is
going to destroy my relationships and my
marriage in this case or and self-esteem
and the vows that i've made before the
community and before god
so
formerly we we said no our true self
is the rational will
our true self is that higher more noble
more human desire and will now we're
saying no it's just our true self is
just being an animal that lower appetite
that is no different than the appetite
of any animal that's our that's our true
self you you give away your whole
humanity
when you give into that ideology that
poor [ __ ] and his poor wife too all
right next one so rich do you get
jealous
uh not really um
or not often
i think the only times i
have got jealous is probably is is when
the guy is older than me and more
successful than me i don't like that
but if they're younger they got
washboard abs whatever for whatever
reason in my mind
not a threat
if they're older they've got gray hair
and
they drive around a fancy car and
they're wearing dollars then i'm like
that guy
no light i don't know why my brain works
that way it's just how it works
i can't tell with this guy if he's into
it
because
again traditionally a cuckold is someone
who
unwittingly and against his will and
without his knowledge has his wife
stooping other guys but now it's taken
on this other connotation in our
extremely depraved and decadent culture
where the guy is in on it where the
husband is in on it and kind of likes it
so i can't tell he's making jokes about
it he doesn't he doesn't seem as sad as
that guy lying on the bed on his on his
wife's arms he's kind of leading the
conversation here he's making jokes so
he might be into it which is in in some
ways
in some ways even sadder that's the
saddest thing i've ever heard that are
those all the cucks we have
okay well the top [ __ ] i'm sorry to say
is is the guy on the bed
he's not the top [ __ ] in that he won
anything i mean the the guy who might
feel like he won something would
probably be that guy at the end who
seems like he's sort of into the whole
situation the guy on the bed just seemed
really sad and saw his marriage collapse
because of this because of the
perversions of his wife and because his
own weakness and lack of fortitude and
courage and moral clarity so
really kind of a sad note to end on but
but that's where we are and it kind of
describes our civilization we've got a
lack of courage which is not only a
virtue but the prerequisite for all of
the other virtues a real lack of moral
clarity these days because all the
standards have been upended and just a
lot of depression going around because
we've got the collapse of all of our
institutions right down to the most
fundamental institution the marriage we
are so
we should probably reverse that don't
you think
do not be a [ __ ] i'm michael knowles see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]